this past week some of my best friends
came to visit me in LA for five days we
slave to make some of the best videos we
could possibly imagine and now that
they've all gone home I finally realize
how important that experience was to me
what I get to do is both an honor and a
privilege and I owe all of it to the
people around me both to my friends and
to you who have supported me so thank
you
hi everybody my name is markiplier and
this is everyone that joins I just want
to say thank you guys so much for having
just the best week but these videos you
may not even see them for a lot of live
recording we got a bunch of different
crafts coming out and it's just going to
be really really awesome I just want to
say thank you for flying Daniel wave for
all coming down to LA lots of people get
together again
and I really hope that we can do this
again really don't everybody of us again
I discuss it as reducing ever also our
speed can you make it scream alright
very expensive equipment nails destroy
whatever
no that's fine oh this is this is the
only thing I did today
Oh either way it was totally awesome so
get ready to see a lot of you iron
production stop coming out in the next
few weeks and it's going to be awesome
thanks for watching
my eyes it's back there to hear your
ring that was blue good